2019 2020 when Trump was President he
trailed all of them this year he's
trailed all of them in our poll first
time in more than a dozen polls we've
seen a result like this and actually now
we are seeing some statistical evidence
of the trouble that they are in uh
because yes Trump is beating Biden in a
bunch of polls I always say you have to
take polls with a Grandin of salt uh but
look what's being reported even in
mainstream media now here it is Donald
Trump we have at 46% Biden 44 and this
is significant because this is the first
time in the history of our poll that
former president Trump beats President
Biden still within the margin of error
but still significant yeah in 2019 2020
when Trump was President he trailed all
of them this year he's trailed all of
them in our poll first time in more than
a dozen polls we've seen a result like
this some of the other ingredients that
go into that Biden has long had an
advantage over Trump un likability look
at the start of this year 39% said they
had a positive view of Biden barely 30
of trump we've seen consistently a gap
like this now the Gap is gone 36
positive on both and actually Biden one
point more negative than Trump that's
been a significant Advantage for Biden
our poll says that Advantage at least
for now may be gone and we talked about
younger voters on foreign policy and
it's true on a host of other topics
disaffected with Joe Biden we have 46%
for Trump 42% for Biden among the
youngest voters the youngest voters in
the 2020 election were Biden plus 26
this could be a massive sea change and
if you take a look here two all
everybody sort of says hey I'm not too
nuts about the possibility of this match
up so we said let's measure this one way
and here's how we did it Biden against
an unnamed Republican this is just a
referendum on Biden basically and look
at this he goes from being a a dog fight
with Trump to be in double digits behind
but then flip it around Trump against an
unnamed Democrat Trump goes from leading
against Biden to being down by six
points against the Democrat just a
fascinating look at the state of the
race with just a little under a year to
go Steve Kaki great stuff thank you so
much for being here I like how they get
that little dorky guy with his mustard
pants that like does he have any other
outfit that guy and he gets up there and
oh my God the numbers now look first of
all if you're Donald Trump and you're
seeing those numbers I know you're
related but on the other hand if you
also believe that they stole the
election from you last time like two
points I don't know if it means that
much but the greater Point here that's
on Meet the Press that wasn't MSNBC
that's NBC's Sunday Meet the Press the
fact that they are now showing those
polls means they cannot deny the fact
that Biden's a struggling and it's
starting to kind of feel cool again to
support Donald Trump right like that's
clearly what's happening here and it
might also be a signal that the
corporate press is now trying as they've
been trying to do for a couple months I
would say uh trying to figure out a way
to give Biden the boot because obviously
no one thinks he's up to the
job